said I was gonna do it but I did it okay
it's exactly that you ready huh I like
clubbing
Oh what's going on YouTube um before we
start this [ __ ] go ahead and don't ask
about this thing right here because it
involves a very short Dorito chip and a
slap to the face recently I did
something that I haven't done in a very
long time don't sex that's right over
the weekend a few friends came over they
wanted to go clubbing
up in LA so we went to a club called
Club boy which by the way was packed
full of Asian people there were so many
Asian people there look like a Beijing
flea market anyways
imma let you know straight-up how I feel
about clubs Hey Hey look I hate club hi
Baby Bop why do you hate clever so much
what aren't you sociable or something
like that don't you like meeting people
don't you like go ahead and talk to
people all the time no no no I hate
clubbing
I hate clubs and these are the reasons
why I'm fat and no it's not a
self-esteem thing no I don't think that
I'm not beautiful or something like that
let me tell you something volume skinny
ask people here's an equation that you
should remember for the rest of your
life fat equals sweaty axe I sweat a lot
in a club and no I don't wear black
because I think it's slimming okay I
went black because it hides my sweat
stains very well in a dark area oh my
god is that a sweat stain huh what no
the fattest whis thing close your eyes
and look at me the same time he's good
the box number two why the hell is it
that girls always get into clothes for
free pump it's honestly that's some
[ __ ] what is cuz you all got titties
titties - what if I squeeze my lips
together does that help does that help
yesterday there was this girl that got
in my face about you know women and men
have an equal rights which I believe
into women and men are equal in every
single aspect and let's be real women
are sometimes better at things a min on
let me tell you something the next time
there's a draft of the war your
equal-opportunity ass is coming with me
you don't saying tell me why - shake ass
is over here being sent out to war to
protect the country while big-ass china
from WWF is staying at home lifting
weights
does that make sense every time you had
a club you got to order a drink and you
know what I'll be honest with you
youtube go ahead and judge me fellas I
don't like beer unlike you I hate it
like [ __ ] and you know what every single
drinking I like is the so-called girly
drinks be honest for a second YouTube
because I open up a menu and there's a
drink that has you know passion fruit
strawberry peaches and on the right side
there's beer that says wheat and barley
and imma be out how to choose this drink
because it's more manly that's some
[ __ ]
and it sucks too because every single
drink that I like that sounds good has a
weird-ass name to it so every time I
order it I get defensive
oh hey bartender let me get up and get a
UH [ __ ] popper I'm trying what was that
up here let me get a beer what a [ __ ]
pop nobody said what don't be tell me I
have mmm I hate getting rejected that's
right ladies I hate it and number one
let me take something ladies if you
don't reject somebody just do it
straight up don't go ahead and be making
all these excuses and finding creative
ways to reject the man because we have
feelings too if you don't want to dance
they straight up say you don't want to
dance don't make it up some stupid
excuse all right cuz I be defensive for
that area too now it's okay I'm a
lesbian I don't like penis okay anybody
wanna dance with you anyways with your
lopsided ass titties biggie smalls I
want to talk to you and another thing
stop stop responding back with sarcasm
okay because it's rude and I'll be off
is cuz my answer so stupid sometimes I
can't pick up on his on my thumb matches
over here just playing along with it yo
baby what's up big hey let me get your
number with what was it wanting him to
go to hell wait she gave me the signal
are y'all roommates or something house
music and I'm not saying I hate house
music but I'm just saying I hate house
music can't just be me thinking this but
I'm not sure if he just because it was
Asian club that you know we're just
playing techno and house all day tell me
something how the [ __ ] do you dance to
house music I don't know that was the
first time I was in a club and I was
absolutely clueless I'm not saying I'm
the best dancer in the world but when it
comes down to a beat you know mom
I don't know how to dance that [ __ ] I
saw a whole group of eight who's just
jumping in the air and fist pumping all
day is that what you do at a club you
know I'm over kid dancing with the girl
of beat comes on we doing our thing and
all of a sudden house music turns on she
starts jumping the air fist pumping and
all six other dudes start doing it
around it too and they cock-blocking me
house music is the biggest [ __ ] block in
the world because you can never dance
one-on-one with the person everybody
gotta jump in I swear I was at the club
and I started doing my Kim jong-in the
moves here pasta dice pasta dice
everybody I started doing it to it
that's the [ __ ] damn I'm sweating up in
here
Jesus like I said that people sweat you
know I'm saying do you work out or
something nah man I just peeled an
orange anyways club I got that off my
chest but on a bigger note guess what
people because your help
I hit a hundred thousand subscribe I've
been trying to figure out a way to get
you guys involved in one of my videos so
there is an idea that I'm gonna put out
and I'm gonna put up a video on how to
how to go ahead and be involved in this
in the next couple of days and the idea
is called not gonna tell you what stay
tuned for in the next three days I'm
gonna go ahead and give you all the
rules to this thing just so you guys can
get involved and be a part of my video
it's gonna be real fun it's gonna be
something that I can do for you guys and
I'm here just you know to service you
that's alright but before I bounce out
of this I'm here to say thank you guys
because um and I know you guys hear it a
lot from a lot of youtubers out there
that when they say thank you and maybe
you guys don't feel it but i'ma let you
know right now thank you
so just remember one thing you guys
aren't really fancy me to me you guys
are like my family so I'm bringing in
bring it in I don't want to get all
emotional [ __ ] but I just knew in the
moment did not that was my crime fish I
won't see it again
I'm calling how Oh
you're my ladies and I can let you let a
bathing in a [ __ ] public pond
what Asia Asian people ain't got no
class my ass
this will swim me toward me look away
know what you're not doing anything